hi my name is santos lowe i'm an la
based food stylist and today i'm going
to show you how i style a barbecue bacon
cheeseburger with creamy slaw
when i'm thinking about this burger i'm
thinking about the bottom to the top and
i'm also thinking about the angle of the
camera in this case we're going to shoot
the burger at eye level when i build
this burger i've run it through my head
not exaggerating
probably 300 times for this burger i'm
gonna use a brioche bun
i love using brioche bun because it's
already glamorous all i need to do is
give it a nice toast making sure that
it's golden i like to use a cast iron
skillet because it gives me more even
heat so i'm not gonna have parts of the
bun that are more toasted than the other
part
once the bun is down i rotate the bun
just to ensure that i get even toasting
i constantly check the bun and i like to
press the edges of the bun as a toast
just to make sure that it's making
contact with the pan
once the bottom bun is nicely toasted on
the inside
roll it around just a little bit on the
edges so i'm not looking for necessarily
an even browning just a little bit here
and there i think that'll give it a nice
touch in the end
now it's time for the bacon
i chose a thick cut maple bacon because
ultimately this burger is going to be
pretty stacked and i want you to be able
to see the bacon immediately start the
pan on a medium-low heat if the pan were
on too high heat the bacon would just
fry and overcook quickly
when cooking this bacon i like not to
put it on the pan flat nestle it in the
pan in a way so that it curls when i put
it on the burger these curves are going
to give the burger volume and it's also
going to create shelves for the slaw to
hang onto and rest on as i'm turning the
bacon over i'm allowing all these
natural curls to happen helping it
happen by lifting it if i have to
once the bacon is done i'm just going to
set it aside and get ready to cook the
patties
lightly coat the cast iron pan with a
little bit of vegetable oil too much oil
is going to fry my meat
a blend of 80 20 which means 80 percent
lean beef to 20 percent fat this blend
is going to yield a patty that has more
texture i like to use my fingers to
press the meat from the center to the
outside using my thumb and my finger it
doesn't necessarily have to be perfect
but it should be round any cracks that i
see right now i want to make sure to
pinch those together because as it cooks
the crack will just split more form the
patty so that it is about a half inch
bigger than the the bun itself it's
going to shrink a little bit but not
very much the cooked patty should stick
out a quarter inch or so i like to press
the edges of the patty to make sure that
i get contact my approach is to first
sear it on a flat cast iron scale i'm
then going to transfer it onto a grill
pan and give it those nice grill marks
and then just carefully and gently
sear the edges
the edges are important because that's
what you're going to see
now i'm heating my cast iron grill pan a
meat that is fried is going to look too
crusty a meat that is seared is going to
yield a deeper brown
color
grease the ridges just a little bit with
vegetable oil and once the pan starts to
smoke i'm going to take my burger patty
and i'm going to press it into the marks
firm but gentle i don't want to
move this around too much because i want
the marks to be clear
and bold see these little crevices in
here that's really nice all right these
burger patties are looking really good
right now
later if i have to cut this in half i
know that it's going to be a juicy
medium well done burger
i have the standard slaw ingredients
cabbage carrot and some green onions now
for the cabbage i've selected green and
purple just to add that touch of color
whenever i'm working with cabbage i like
to peel away the first layer or two to
reveal the more fresher crispier
interior
when it comes time to
slice cabbage for a slaw the lengthwise
sliced cabbage yields a better product
for this recipe it's lighter and as you
can see here it's gonna provide me a lot
of volume when preparing anything for a
food styling job i'm always thinking two
or three steps ahead so i know that this
creamy dressing that i'm gonna fold into
this salad is gonna weigh the vegetables
down and so if i can cut the cabbage in
a way which gives me volume it's going
to help prevent that when cooking food i
get into a zone and i begin to think
several steps ahead because this is
gonna pay off later the next vegetable
i'm gonna prepare is the carrots i'm
just gonna simply cut these into
two to three inch
long segments and then thinly slice
these into planks stack the planks
together i want to cut these super thin
so that they give me volume
and here we go with the scallion i'm
going to cut these as thinly as i can
just as i did the carrots and the
cabbage the end product is going to look
so so good
all my veggies are prepped i'm going to
set these aside and prepare the coleslaw
dressing
for this dressing i have the usual
suspects i have of course the mayo i'm
gonna add a little bit of yellow mustard
for tang i love using smoked paprika in
this because it's going to give the
overall dressing a
nice rose color
let's add a couple dashes of vinegar
and i also like to add honey sometimes
recipes like this call for sugar but i
instead like to use honey because it'll
also give the dressing a thickness
let's look at how the dressing clings to
the whisk imagine the whisk being pieces
of cabbage
this is looking really good it's coating
the whisk
and it's dripping but it's not running
off of it
now that we have all of our prep done
it's finally time to build this bacon
barbecue cheeseburger
flavor-wise
this burger's gonna be fantastic but my
priority is
is a visual one the first thing that i
ask is how is the food being shot in
this case the burger is being shot at
eye level i am designing this burger to
that angle 70 of it is probably game
plan and 30
i'm just gonna leave up to the moment um
i'm gonna improvise it's what's gonna
make this burger special let's give this
bun a little bit of shine we gave it
color now it's time to highlight that
color and i'm simply going to do this by
touching it here and there with a little
bit of vegetable oil not too much i
don't want to grease this bun down but i
definitely want to highlight some of
those beautiful toasted areas i picked a
barbecue sauce that was on the red side
as opposed to a brown barbecue sauce
when the burger patty is placed on top
the sauce is going to gently fall over
the edge of the bun i'm also going to
add a little bit of sauce underneath one
side of the bun just to make it look
like the sauce fell over the bun i just
think it looks really nice
a burger like this has to have pickles
these are what's called bread and butter
pickles want to pick out the ones that
are not perfectly round but that have a
more organic shape to them and i like to
pull them off so that they
hang over the bun just a little bit and
i love the green color of these pickles
too i noticed that the the shelf stable
pickles are not as bright as these
here's the burger patty that we seared
with the really nice grill marks i'm
just going to brush a little bit of oil
onto sides and around the edges
all right here's the cheddar cheese how
i place this cheese is very important
because once i melt the cheese the
cheese is stuck to the meat and there
are many ways to melt cheese on a burger
patty when food styling i like to use a
heat gun because i feel it just gives me
more control i want to make sure to melt
the hard edges of the cheese so that
they become more round and begin to hug
that meat just a little bit now the
cheese is melted on the patty i have to
make sure that i put this exposed part
of the burger facing the front of the
camera the burger patty is the star of
the show oh that looks really good
the next part of this is the bacon the
bacon just like the beef patty just
needs a little bit of love brushing it
with oil makes it look like it was just
cooked
the next thing that goes on now is this
law i'm simply just going to
dollop some of this dressing directly
onto the vegetables and mix them with my
hand i feel that this is going to give
me more control and then what i like to
do is just gently massage the sauce into
the slaw and then build a mound that i
like before i add the slaw i need to
prep the top bun and so just like i did
with the bottom bun
i am going to add a little bit of oil to
some of the toasted areas around the
edge and then i'm going to spread some
barbecue sauce on it as well
the one thing that i know about a bacon
barbecue cheeseburger is that it's
supposed to be a little bit messy and so
that is part of my goal is to have a
little bit of drippage a little bit of
sauce on the plate like that's all good
just like in the arcade rooms where the
crane comes over and tries to grab that
toy i'm gonna gently grab a handful of
this law
carefully place it onto the burger
and now all i need to do is just give
some of these stray pieces of cabbage
some direction
okay now it's time to add the top of the
bun now once this is down it's down
there's no turning back from here here
we go
oh that feels really good
so as i'm putting this bun down i don't
want to smash all of that volume that i
created in the slaw i want to just sort
of nestle this sauce into the slaw
because this burger is all about height
i've allowed the food to speak if the
sauce wants to come over the bun and
spill onto the plate
that's great because that's what sauce
does if the cheese wants to melt a
little bit too far down the meat that's
great too because that's what cheese
does and so i feel that my job as a food
stylist is to help the food do what it
wants to do whenever i finish styling
food the first thing that comes to mind
is
how is the audience going to read this
is it going to be i want to eat this for
me
what makes a successful styled food that
needs to define the recipe i need to
look at it and immediately be able to
say that looks like what i was supposed
to make there's a feeling that i can't
really describe this feeling has to do
with subconsciously comparing it to
millions of images i've seen a burger
thousands of burgers that i've eaten and
hundreds of burgers that i've actually
styled and all of that just sort of
comes together as i'm staring at this
burger that i just made when i look at
it i can just know
it's good
or it's not
oh yes
[Music]
you